dolly ist eine Website auf der man
irgendeinen Satz eingeben kann wie
beispielsweise eine Frau die eine Pfanne
voll mit Hamburgern in der Hand hält und
dann kriegt man einfach auf generate und
die Website malt einem das und das
innerhalb von extrem kurzer
okay ich glaube die Website braucht ein
bisschen schwierigere Aufgabe obwohl die
Frau hier jetzt auch nicht allzu gesund
aussieht ihr müsst halt überlegen dass
sie keine Person oder irgendein Künstler
hinter der Website steckt sondern das
Ganze durch ey
zeichnet wird eh alles auch wirklich
sehr Begriff des Jahres bisher ich würde
allerdings sagen dass in der Webseite
jetzt einen schwierigeren Satz geben und
zwar ein Haus das drei Ballons an sich
befestigt hat und über einen Berg fliegt
ich habe keine Ahnung wie man Gehirn auf
na okay das geht schon ein bisschen
besser aber auch sehr speziell
genau
ich würde sagen wir nehmen jetzt mal ein
bisschen was Verrücktes und zwar in old
woman taking is selfie with the toast da
klicken auf generate und jetzt seht ihr
auch mal wie schnell das hier wirklich
geht also ich habe jetzt quasi
eingegeben eine alte Frau die ein selfie
mit einem Toaster macht es geht
natürlich nicht aber es ist natürlich
das heißt diese
[Musik]
ja okay man kann es halt auf beide Arten
sehen ne das hier ist jeweils eine Frau
die ein selfie mit dem Handy macht mit
einem Toaster auf dem Bild drauf und das
hier sind jeweils zwei Frauen die
selfies wirklich mit einem Toaster in
der Hand machen und das krasseste ist
und das muss man sich wirklich mal auf
der Zunge zergehen lassen dass keine
dieser Personen wirklich existiert
das sind alles vom Computer generierte
Personen die nirgends wo jemals gelebt
haben das krasse an der Webseite ist
allerdings auch das wird beispielsweise
sagen können hey dieses Foto hier
gefällt uns besonders gut die Frau macht
ein selfie mit ihrem Handy und hat ein
Toaster drauf klicken auf veriations und
bekommen dann tatsächlich basierend auf
diesem Bild was wir uns gerade
ausgesucht haben noch mal ein paar
andere Varianten vorgeschlagen
das ist halt so krass wirklich für
Youtuber die in thumbnail machen wollen
schaut man das hier ist das Original und
ich zwei gerade die ganze Zeit schon
recht rüber das sind einfach ähnliche
Bilder die eine gleiche Richtung gehen
ich setze mich in letzter Zeit sehr viel
mit dem ganzen Thema auseinander und wie
es mir eventuell Arbeit in Zukunft
abnehmen kann und bin dabei auf dieses
Video von mkbh die gestoßen der das hier
schon vor Jahren entdeckt hat in diesem
Video hat er die ganze Technik hinter
dieser Website auch noch mal erklärt und
erläutert und auch gezeigt dass man
sogar Bilder dort hochladen kann
dementsprechend habe ich gerade bereits
ein selfie von mir aufgenommen und werde
dieses Bild jetzt einfach mal auf die
Website ja und jetzt sagt die Website
uns basierend auf dem Bild was wir
hochgeladen haben wie eventuell
Variationen von unserem Gesicht oh mein
Gott
oh mein Gott
ich habe dieses Bild hier hochgeladen
auf der Website und das hier
sind die Variationen
die die Webseite mir basieren darauf
anzeigt
es ist
es ist absolut crazy was wäre denn wenn
ich jetzt ein Bild hochladen wo ich so
einen krassen Filter im Gesicht habe
ich bin wirklich gespannt ob die Website
Dame jetzt auch Variationen wird weil
sie wird wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen
dass das wirklich mein Gesicht ist und
das ist kein Filter ist nicht drauf
haben und mir dann wahrscheinlich
Variation zeigen
[Musik]
ey das sieht aus wie in einem Horrorfilm
ich würde allerdings sagen dass wir ein
bisschen outside the box denken müssen
im Moment thinking outside the box macht
vielleicht Sinn ne wenn wir aus der Box
denken müssen dass wir der Webseite das
einfach mal eingeben ich weiß jetzt
nicht genau wie man einen Mann denken
darf
also das hier kommt schon daran ne okay
er sitzt in der Box immer gespannt was
passiert wenn ich mein Logo da hochlade
mein Logo beinhaltet ja kein wirkliches
Gesicht
deswegen bin ich gespannt ob die
Webseite das hinkriegt weil es gibt halt
irgendwie keinen Anhaltspunkt nur vier
Linie
[Musik]
ey das ist wirklich crazy ne
Original und er versucht's wirklich so
einer gewissen Form nachzuzeichnen wir
machen jetzt noch mal was ganz
verrücktes cake driving Bugatti in Italy
also er soll mich jetzt bitte einen
Kuchen generieren der einen Bugatti
fährt und dass ich irgendwo sondern in
Italien ach das ist jetzt ein Bugatti
Kuchen
das ist einfach ein Bugatti Kuchen
vielleicht müssen wir einen anderen Satz
eingeben behind the wheel of the Bugatti
in Italy also ich habe den Satz jetzt
quasi so abgeändert dass ich nicht
geschrieben habe okay driving Bugatti
sondern eine behind the wheel also das
der Kuchen hinter dem Steuer sitzt oh
mein Gott
gut das ist jetzt kein Bugatti sieht er
nach einem Altenessen Martin aus oder so
okay man kann natürlich auch so sein
dass er okay und ja oh mein Gott das ist
krass mit Deutschland machen the Cologne
domfield with water also ich erwarte
jetzt Bilder bzw ich möchte gern Bilder
haben von dem Kölner Dom also der Kirche
hier ne füllt mit Wasser das
ja gut er hat glaube ich nicht so ganz
verstanden dass das Ding in Wasser
gefüllt sein soll aber
so darauf beruhen dass es wirklich ai
Bilder sind weil dieses Gebäude also ich
kenne Kölsch schon relativ gut
mittlerweile da steht dort nicht am
Kölner Dom generell das auch dieser
Springbrunnen der ist hier nicht haben
können und das ist kein Bild das ist
wirklich generiert der Google hier
wahrscheinlich Kölner Dom nimm
irgendwelche Bilder sieht Wasser in dem
Satz und irgendwie Wasser und versucht
es zu verbinden und das alles
als artificial intelligence
das ist unfassbar
[Musik]
young man vor Ding into the microphone
das ist der nächste Satz den ich gern
generiert haben wollen würde da bin ich
nämlich gerade drauf gekommen durch
meinen Furz den ich hier rausgesucht
habe wo vielleicht auch ein bisschen was
mit kamen muss ich gleich mal schauen
auf Toilette komme auch mal machen
gleich mit Toilette wie ein Typ aus der
Toilette
okay vielleicht hätte ich vor dem with
Hills ass schreiben müssen in Alpaka
looking out of the toilet also ein
Alpaka das aus einer Toilette
hinausschaut ich hoffe dass er das
versteht ich glaube da steht auch dass
man
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Playstation 6 gebe ich mal ein man hat
sich dann früher so gefragt wie die
nächste Konsolengeneration aussieht und
dann kam so Bilder bei google mit zum
aufklappbaren Bildschirm mit dem
Bildschirm im Controller drin wo man
auch durch gucken kann Playstation 6
Bildschirm drin ja
das hier soll Player sie hält den
Controller irgendwie ein bisschen falsch
okay das war Playstation 6 darstellen zu
guter Letzt würde ich allerdings sagen
machen wir noch mal was richtig
verrücktes gold with the redhead riding
bicycle on the moon while eating is life
of pizza also eine Ziege mit einem roten
Hut die auf dem Mond ein Fahrrad fährt
und dabei ein Stück Pizza ist das kann
die Website eigentlich nicht schaffen
also das sind so viele
das ergibt keinen Sinn also erstmal das
hier ist ja der Mond also kann ja nicht
auf dem Mond fahren er muss ja
eigentlich
so dass er durch die Erde
nee aber er hat auch kein Hut auf ne
das hier wird vielleicht am ehesten
rankommen
weil das vielleicht die Sonne darstellt
ich weiß es nicht egal wir dürfen der
Website vielleicht auch nicht zu viel
abverlangen es war auf jeden Fall sehr
sehr interessant sich das Ganze jemand
anzuschauen wenn es euch gefallen hat
lasst gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem
Video da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nichts verpassen welche Sätze solche
eventuell in einem zweiten Timer
eingeben
ich weiß nicht ob ein zweiter Teil
kommen wird bin ich ganz ehrlich aber
ich habe halt irgendwie 200 Credits
gekauft oder 150 übrig